-Welcome back.
-Well, thanks, bud.
-I'm happy you made it.
I know you got
a little sidetracked today
You stopped by
the "Hot Ones" studio.
-Oh, you heard.
-Yes.
-Now, you did not do
the full 10 wings.
-I didn't, no.
-Yeah.
-I was there to do a podcast
-Okay.
-But I'm a fan of the show
-Yeah, it's a great show.
-And I was like, "This is wher
they make that
and I've always
wanted to be on it."
I love spicy wings.
I love hot sauce.
So they were like,
"Well, we can arrange for yo
to try some of these sauce
just for social.
We'll do the last dab."
If you're familiar
with the show,
the last dab
is like the hottest one
that they give them at the end
and then they gave us da bomb.
-Yep. I have had da bomb.
Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
-Did you have
a similar reaction?
-I can't believe you agreed to
do it without doing "Hot Ones.
The whole point is to do it an
have people be able to watch
-I know.
-Like, I never would have
done it backstage.
-I know, but I was just excited.
-You were excited.
-Yeah, it was the fun of it.
So myself and Tim League,
who owns the Alamo Drafthous
Cinema, we did it together
and we did them and we're like
"These are really hot."
But had a normal reaction, like,
"We can do this"
and handled it fine.
And then Tim's belly
started to really hurt.
-Yep.
-He stood up
and he ran to the restroom
like he was gonna vomit.
He then ended up on the floo
for about five minutes
of deep, deep pain.
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
-And it was a little traumatic
And I was like, "Oh, man,
I got out of this scot-free.
15 minutes later I'm like,
"Hmm."
[ Laughter ]
"That's a little twinge."
And that, like,
ramped up so fast.
I've had my appendix out.
-Yeah.
-When my appendix burst,
it was the most unimaginable
pain I've ever felt.
I'm not gonna say
this was dissimilar.
It was so bad.
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah.
-So bad.
-It's really not good.
-It was a fireball
in my stomach.
-And I got to be honest.
It's not over for you.
-Okay.
[ Laughter and applause ]
-It's not over for you.
-No, tomorrow is
gonna be interesting.
-You play as we can tell
from the clip,
you play a deejay in this film
-I do.
-You've talked about actuall
deejaying here before.
-Yeah.
-So did you help
cultivate this look
for your deejay character
in this film?
-Yeah, I did, sort of.
So, Ant Timspon, the director,
he had very strange ideas
for who this character was
supposed to look like
that were slightly more extrem
than this and very alien
and it was my job to sort of try
and make it seem
somewhat realistic.
-Because it is a horror film
and so to be a realistic deejay,
I believe helps with the ver
unrealistic horror that will -
You know what I mean, like
-Yeah, yeah, sure.
-Yeah, right.
-Well, the thing is this
character -- the movie is abou
a guy who's trying to reconnec
with his father
whom he has been apart fro
for 30 years.
So the idea is you're supposed
to go on this emotional journey.
It takes wild twists and turns
but you still have to
care about the character.
So in terms of figuring out what
that look was,
it had to be weird
but it couldn't be too weird
-Absolutely.